[Music]
hey hey everybody's got a book
out even Jimmy
failing
yeah Jimmy's got a new book and boy are
both of his fans excited yep it's called
cancel culture dictionary an a toz guide
to winning the war on fun it comes out
next month but you can pre-order it now
if you're in the market for a new door
stop all right so uh Jimmy I'm looking
on the back and I see people that gave
you all the little pull quotes and
phrase uh I one of them is Brian kilme
so uh I thought you wanted to sell
books well I will really quickly sell it
and defend it folks if you like reading
at a third grade level you're going to
love this book okay if you like scratch
and sniff popups I kid but uh some good
quotes and B basically what this book is
about okay if you wanted to know which I
know you don't care but thank you for
letting me promote this okay it's about
how can culture and weaponized
censorship have broken our compass in
society and how we're policing the wrong
things meaning we spend more time
policing comedians than we do the
streets and a lot of times The
Superficial victories we deliver don't
actually help the Agri communities take
Native American mascots okay we didn't
actually help Native Americans by
canceling the Redskins never mind that
we didn't choose Native American mascots
to mock the culture there's a pride in
calling yourself a chief if you don't
believe me ask Elizabeth Warren you know
what I mean so I think this is an
opportunity to give people perspective
that's what I was going for very very
succinct um you also have a pull quote
here from Jesse
Waters um I know for a fact he did not
read your book uh not not even a page
not even a page he just like and he
probably didn't even write this this was
probably he had probably had his
assistant John Johnny Johnny is Johnny
is great uh no but Waters speaks truth
to power he refers to me as the ratings
fairy which as you know I'm great for
Ratings so kudos to John you're a fairy
thank you well you've seen the outfits
you've seen the outfits uh but that's
too
funny so uh um am I mentioned at all in
this book or you actually are and in a
flattering way I actually do it listen I
thank you you have done so do you think
I'd be having this book do you think
they would have chose me to have a book
ghost written with my name on it were it
not for
you I'm kidding I wrote it myself and
you'll know because you know I'm not
Hemingway but I sound like I hang out at
a bar named Hemingways like you will
love this what was your writing
discipline how did you uh were you did
you do a lot of research or was it I
gotta be honest this book would not be
possible without Delta flight delays
because I wrote this a lot if it wasn't
for the terrible conditions of
commercial air travel this book doesn't
happen but I wrote a lot obviously in
Terminals and in our offices earlier in
the day Comedy Club green rooms but
basically it's an A to Z it's not a
dictionary but it's laid out an a toz
because each letter is something that
got canceled by letter and then I
explain like how this impacted society
and how nobody actually benefited from
it that's the point is they've they've
cancel culture has created I call it a
war on fun because we are policing
sources of joy for grievance movies
things like that most of the people that
have led the charge on cancel culture
don't like fun no not at all fun people
they usually failed at what they're
trying to take down exact a good example
of that would be Shane Gillis on
Saturday Night Live Shane Gillis got
canceled off Saturday Night Live because
people dug up old podcasts about him who
do you think these people were people
who dreamed of being on Saturday Night
Live but could never get there and they
were like we'll kneecap this kid and
that's that's a lot of 10 times funnier
than anybody oh he's amazing he's great
so that's probably the point all right
well uh I'm glad I was able to promote
this book even though I was not
mentioned on the
back you're meent you are mentioned all
the way throughout the Book thank you
that's all that matters he only resents
the book cuz it's taller than he is
a hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most comp in analysis you will not get
it anywhere
else